Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
Welcome back to my season 4 countdown. 13
more days to go.
the other day in my Game of Thrones Movie
video I asked you all to submit questions
about the back end of the series and possible
movie stories.
So I picked 10 to answer in this video and
one bonus question.
If you’re just now finding me I’m doing
a special countdown to the season 4 premiere.
Once that starts I’ll be doing weekly videos
just like my Walking Dead stuff and a weekly
giveaway.
Make sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to suggest topics for bonus videos.
Let’s answer so questions.
Careful for potential spoilers.
Most of this is about prequel material.
So it shouldn’t be a huge deal.
Question 1 - Lady Cersei asks How much will
Jaime’s perspective differ from the books?﻿
Just because the timeline is messed up a little?
So in the books Jaime doesn’t get back to
King’s Landing till way later in the story.
Meaning he’s going to be there to witness
some things.
In all honesty, they way they’ve been developing
all the characters involved.
I don’t think his character will feel or
act any differently than he did in the books.
There will be a few new scenes.
That didn’t happen in the books, but only
for continuity with the story the show is
telling.
So short answer, for the most part, he’ll
still be the same.
His character arc won’t change.
Whic is good, because he’s going to be one
of my favorite characters this season.
Question 2 - Neto del Toro asks How many movies
do you think they could get out of the dance
of the dragons story?
For those who don’t know, the dance of the
dragons was a Targaryen civil war that took
place a long time before events on the show.
I think they could totally turn into int a
Lord of The Rings, Hobbit Trilogy.
That seems to be the style now a days with
these huge epic adaptations.
Turn what would normally be one movie into
three.
And make three times as much money.
Not that I would complain if they did that.
It would mean an extra 4-5 years of movies.
Assuming they start with one trilogy.
I think if they did a movie though, they would
start with the characters currently on the
show.
Just to give George RR Martin time to finish
Dream of Spring.
Question 3 - Shihab Shabbir asks What do you
think the upcoming game of thrones game will
be about?﻿
If you’re talking about the one Telltale
Games is working on, it will involve the current
characters.
Starting with the first book.
They’ll probably expand on events and give
us a chance to see battles and places that
don’t appear in the books.
Or events that are only mentioned briefly.
It’s possible that they could also do a
prequel story in a future season too.
Telltale’s Walking Dead game used a different
character than the tv series.
But either way, they’re a great company
and I’ll be making gameplay videos when
it comes.
It’s not being released till December this
year.
So that’s a long ways off.
I’ll try to get my hands on a pre-release
copy though.
Question 4 - Alex Garcia asks What are the
chances of seeing a #GOT Robert's Rebellion
series that would fill in the gaps of Jon
Snow's birth?﻿
I think it’s more likely that they’d tell
that in a flashback.
Rather than dedicate an entire movie to it.
Any movie would really just tie up whatever
they didn’t have time for in the final season.
Or setup a spinoff franchise like Dunk and
Egg.
I think Jon Snow will find out who his mother
is before the end of the series.
Whether he figures it out himself or someone
tells him.
Question 5 - Matthew Blanche (no avatar) asks
do you think the show will start hinting at
big events that haven't appeared in the novels
yet?﻿
You’re talking about if the show starts
to pass the books.
Martin said he think’s he’s got through
season 5 before that happens.
By which time he’ll have finished Winds
of Winter, giving him about two more seasons.
It’s really not until we get to Season 7
that he’s in trouble.
It’s way too soon to tell, but remember
Martin told David Benioff and DB Weiss what
the ending was in case that happened.
They just needed to know because they’re
already planning season 5 and they don’t
want to kill a character that’s really important
later in the story.
And it helps them know where everyone needs
to be moving forward.
So short answer, yes.
They’ll pass Martin, but not for a couple
more seasons.
Question 6 - Christina Barton asks how do
you put all the info in your videos?
Hey nice channel, thanks for asking about
how I make videos.
Normally I already have an idea of what I
want to say and then I just do research in
books and forums to get facts straight.
It’s not super complicated, but if I’m
making a really long video with a lot of information.
It takes a long time to collect all those
facts.
And I don’t read from a teleprompter, but
I do write what I want to say down.
Just to get it straight in my head.
And so I can make subtitles.
Question 7 - Vermalgab Boom asks Has there
been anything written about the Doom?﻿
Yes, but the book called “The World of Ice
And Fire” isn’t being released till October
this year.
So you can read more about Ancient Valyria
in that.
I’ll be sure to do a review when it comes
out.
Martin is also writing a book called “Fire
and Blood”.
And it’s the complete history of House Targaryen,
which existed in Old Valyria.
That book won’t be written till after Dream
of Spring though.
Question 8 - Bang Maid asks Did GRRM indicate
whether the movies would be continued under
the supervision of Benioff and Weiss?
No, he didn’t say anything about that.
And they just re-upped their contract with
HBO for season 5.
Which means that it’s possible, but not
likely that they could leave the show before
it’s over.
I don’t think that’s going to happen.
It’s been so successful under them that
there’s no reason for them to leave.
Unless HBO refuses to pay them more money.
Question 9 - Chris B asks which two characters
would you most like to see meet each other?
Daenerys, Jon Snow and Tyrion.
My own person dream team for the Three Heads
of the Dragon.
Even if that’s not necessarily the way the
prophecy will go down.
Tyrion studies a lot of dragonlore, so I think
he’ll be associated with the dragons at
some point.
Whether or not he gets to ride one.
We’ll have to see.
Question 10 - Candoran2 (no avatar) asks How
does one become a greenseer?﻿
So one person in a thousand is born a skinchanger,
people that can Warg.
And one Skinchanger in a thousand is born
a greenseer.
On the show, the three eyed raven is the only
greenseer in the world, Bran is the next one.
That’s why it’s so easy for him to warg
into people like Hodor.
Normal skinchangers can’t do that.
Based on the images in the trailer, we’re
going to see a lot of the greenseer story
play out.
Who else was disappointed when the eyes on
the weirwood tree didn’t open.
Bonus Question - Melanie Rojas asks do you
subscribe to the R+L theory of Jon Snow’s
parents?
I do, yes.
For the simple reason that it lines up logically
with what we know about all those characters
and the timeline of events during Robert’s
Rebellion.
And it would put Jon Snow in a very specific
place going into the battle with the great
other.
As in it would validate a lot of the azor
ahai and three heads of the dragon theories.
It would also get him tied up in ancient blood
magic which just sounds so awesome.
For all intents and purposes.
His character would just be 10 times more
interesting if the R+L theory is true.
It’s the most logical guess given the facts
we have.
DB Weiss and David Benioff were able to guess
it immediately after reading the first four
books.
So it’s not a super mystery.
Anyone is welcome to pose alternate theories,
but thanks so much for submitting your questions.
My next countdown video will probably be my
top 10 moments from season 3.
But feel free to leave me suggestions in the
comments below.
Right now click here to learn about the history
of dragons in the world and click here for
the rest of my season 4 countdown videos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!